donde nos quedamos en el último vídeo
habíamos expresado nuestra integral de
línea a lo largo a lo largo de la
frontera a nuestra superficie de esta
frontera estamos calculando la integral
de línea sobre la frontera de ese punto
de r donde la trayectoria era la
frontera de s ese era nuestra superficie
ok entonces esta está le expresamos en
términos al final de una integral de
línea esta integral de línea pero
alrededor de una curva c1 donde se 1era
la frontera de nuestra región r y la
razón por la cual esto será valioso para
nosotros es porque podremos usar el
teorema de green directamente a esta a
esta última expresión de acá abajo y
llevarlo a una integral doble sobre la
región
r acotada ok entonces así que vamos a
hacerlo vamos a utilizar el teorema de
green vamos a usar el teorema de green y
vamos a aplicarlo directamente aquí
entonces vamos a usar él
teorema de green
de green
ok y vamos a utilizarlo sobre esta
última que esta última realmente la
obtuvimos de esta expresión de aquí
abajo
aunque nosotros utilizamos esta
expresión de aquí abajo para llegar de
esta última integral o esta penúltima
donde sobre la región digamos sobre la
línea donde está definido el parámetro t
lo utilizábamos para llevarlo a una
integral de línea sobre la trayectoria
cerrada c 1 entonces vamos a usar el
teorema de green que es lo que nos dice
el teorema de green que esta integral la
podremos llevar a una integral doble
sobre nuestra región r de quien de la
derivada parcial respecto de x de la
segunda parte es decir de q q más r por
la derivada de z respecto de i
eso mismo con blanco y después hay que
restar la derivada parcial respecto de y
de la primera parte que es p
de más de bs es la derivada de zeta
respecto de x
vamos a cerrar esto y hay que
multiplicar por nuestra diferencial de
área
entonces lo que queremos es ver que
llegamos a la misma expresión que
teníamos aquí arriba eso es lo que nos
gustaría para finalmente decir que el
teorema de 'stocks' es cierto al menos
para este este caso especial que nos
estamos tomando entonces hay que
recordar muy bien quiénes eran pq y r
aquí estaban las funciones pq y r donde
p q r dependen de x jay-z pero no hay
que perder de vista algo z es una
función que depende de xy de y entonces
realmente pq jr dependen de x y y de
zeta que al final de cuentas depende de
xy de y entonces a la hora de derivar
parcialmente respecto de x o de alguna
de estas funciones tendremos que cuidar
muy bien cómo lo hacemos tenemos que
usar la regla de la cadena en varias
variables porque al final de cuentas q
puede cambiar respecto de x pues
simplemente cambiando respecto de x o
también puede cambiar respecto de z que
después cambia respecto de x correcto
porque z puede cambiar respecto d
entonces si esto no te ha confundido
mucho vamos a seguir vamos a tomar la
derivada parcial respecto de x de q yo
creo que con un ejemplo será mucho mejor
entonces como derivamos respecto de q
pues primero simplemente podemos tomar
la derivada de q respecto de x pero
también podemos tomar la derivada de q
respecto de zeta y multiplicar por la
derivada de zeta respecto de x todo esto
es el cambio que puede tener q respecto
de x verdad esto es simplemente haber
usado la regla de la cadena ahora bien
también si por ejemplo queremos tomar la
derivada respecto de x de esta segunda
parte de ere por la derivada de zeta
respecto de ye pues primero tenemos que
usar la regla del producto que me dice
es primero la derivada de este primero
por el segundo más la derivada del
segundo por el primero entonces
tendremos que tomar la derivada de r
respecto de xy multiplicarlo por la
derivada de 7 respecto de jay ahorita
vemos que más tenemos que agregar
entonces como derivó r
respecto de x pues igual que cuando
derivamos a q tomamos la derivada de r
respecto de x y también puede cambiar
respecto de z que cambia respecto de x
ok esto fue haber utilizado la regla de
la cadena y hay que multiplicar por el
otro término que es la derivada de zeta
respecto de ella y ahora hay que sumar
la otra parte la la derivada respecto de
x de la derivada de zeta respecto de iu
por r eso simplemente es la derivada de
zeta respecto de iu y luego respecto de
x que multiplica a la función r muy bien
ya tenemos esta primera parte vamos a
sacar esta segunda entonces vamos a
calcular la derivada parcial respecto
del pp quien es eso la derivada parcial
de t respecto y después es simplemente
la derivada de t respecto de y más la
derivada de p respecto de z porque z
puede cambiar respecto de ella entonces
esto fue haber utilizado la regla de la
cadena y vamos a
todo esto que vamos a ir encontrando
ahora la derivada parcial respecto de
jett de esta segunda parte dejen de
utilizar los mismos colores que use
anteriormente entonces de forma muy
parecida podemos ver que esto es la
derivada parcial de r respecto de ye más
la derivada parcial de r respecto de z
por la derivada de z respecto de y que
multiplica al otro término que en este
caso es la derivada de zeta respecto de
x y hay que sumar ahora la la derivada
de zeta primero respecto de de de quien
derivamos primero de x y luego vamos a
derivar respecto de y que multiplica a r
entonces aquí utilizamos la regla del
producto en esta en este es el segundo
término ahora bien vamos a utilizar un
poquito de álgebra para ver que esto es
esencialmente es lo mismo que teníamos
arriba porque bueno primero vamos a
simplificar vamos a dejar esto igual la
primera parte en rojo la derivada de q
respecto de x
la derivada de q respecto de z por la
derivada de 7 respecto de x y vamos a
hacer vamos a distribuir este producto
entonces tendremos
la derivada de respecto de x que
multiplica la derivada de zeta respecto
de y es simplemente hacer esta
multiplica multiplicación más la
derivada de r respecto de z por la
derivada de zeta respecto x por la
derivada de zeta respecto de iu y ahora
hay que sumar este último término que es
la derivada de aceptar primero respecto
de ella y luego respecto de x por r y
vamos a restar la parte de acá abajo
vamos a restar la ching vamos a hacerlo
con el mismo color la derivada vamos a
restar la derivada de p respecto de y
menos la derivada de t respecto de z por
la derivada de z respecto de y menos y
hacemos este es la distribución de este
producto y es la derivada de r
hacerlo con el mismo color azul menos la
derivada de r por la derivada de 7
respecto de x menos la derivada de r
respecto de zeta ceta jay-z x y hay que
restar también esta última parte que es
la derivada de zeta respecto de xy luego
respecto de ye por r y ahora hay que
notar algo hay que simplificar esto
porque si nos damos cuenta estos dos
términos son los mismos excepto que
invertía el orden de los productos
entonces esto es esencialmente lo mismo
y ahora también recordemos algo muy
importante que nuestra función zeta
tenía que ser déjenme ver si lo escribí
aquí aquí lo escribí que sus derivadas
de segundo orden son continuas lo cual
nos dice que sus derivadas cruzadas son
iguales entonces si eso es cierto
estas estos dos términos son también
iguales entonces se pueden cancelar sin
ningún problema y finalmente al
simplificar esto es lo que nos queda
dentro de la integral sobre la región r
por lo tanto vamos a expresar lo pero
con un poquito de preámbulo porque
queremos llegar a esta expresión
entonces vamos a factorizar lo que tiene
la derivada de zeta respecto de x y lo
que tiene la derivada de zeta respecto
de iu y lo que no tiene nada para ver si
se parece o no a eso que quiere que
quisiéramos llegar ok entonces nos
tomamos vamos a tomarnos con azul como
estaba arriba lo que tiene la derivada
parcial resta de z respecto de x que son
estos dos entonces tenemos la derivada
de zeta respecto de x que multiplica a
la derivada de q respecto de zeta menos
la derivada de r respecto de i
y ahora si factor izamos lo que tiene la
derivada parcial respecto de la derivada
de zeta respecto de jay que son estos
dos tendremos la derivada de zeta
respecto de ella que multiplica a la
derivada de r respecto de x menos la
derivada de p respecto de zeta y sumamos
lo que no tiene nada es decir estos dos
entonces tendremos la derivada de q
respecto de x menos la derivada de p
respecto de ella y esto sí esto sí es lo
que hay que integrar a lo largo de
nuestra región r y hay que multiplicarlo
por nuestra diferencial de área entonces
vamos a ver vamos a ver si esta última
expresión que obtuvimos déjenme copiarla
y pegarla es igual a la que teníamos
arriba entonces copiamos
vamos a ver si es igual a ésta
vamos a pegarla y fíjense nada más yo sé
que se está encimando ahorita pero bueno
lo voy a quitar en unos momentos
entonces estas dos integrales ya pudimos
haber visto que son idénticas no tienen
ningún cambio excepto quizás en en los
colores así que nuestra integral de
línea vamos a retomarlo todo lo que
estamos viendo acá arriba nuestra
integral de línea del campo vectorial
sobre la curva se se simplificó a esa
última expresión a esta a esta de aquí y
la integral de superficie también se
simplificó a lo mismo así que usando las
suposiciones que teníamos ambas se si se
simplifican a la misma cosa entonces
ahora sabemos que para este caso
especial en donde la superficie está
dada por la gráfica de una función la
integral de línea esta integral de línea
es igual a la integral de superficie ya
hemos acabado demostrando que el teorema
de stocks para este caso es cierto